a lot is in store right now for the
future of Marvel Studios 2023 is almost
over however we had a lot of super
intriguing rumors and reports happened
this year that tell us about the future
of the MCU and in today's video we are
going to go over the big ones that we
heard that will really affect the future
of the MCU however important disclaimer
the firing of Jonathan Majors as king
the Conqueror in the MCU did change some
of the plans that Marvel Studios had for
the MCU moving forward of course and
we've talked about this in depth on the
channel in several videos we won't dive
too deep into it today but basically
what you need to know is that Kang isn't
done many insiders have reported that
Kang is still going to be a villain of
the Multiverse Saga however of course
they're going to recast Kang the
Conqueror and we probably won't see much
of Kang until Avengers Secret Wars or
right before Avengers Secret Wars
according to several insiders that is
the plan and we talked about this
yesterday but a big plan that Marvel
Studios has now since K the Conqueror is
going to be kind of swept under the rug
for the meantime is to bring in the
X-Men sooner than expected we went into
great detail about this in yesterday's
video check that out after if you want
but essentially the gist of Marvel
studios's plans for the X-Men is to
bring them in sooner than they expected
to they didn't really plan to introduce
any new X-Men characters till phase
seven of the MCU after the Multiverse
Saga but since Kang is going to be kind
of put on the sidelines for a while they
need something to really get fans
excited and the X-Men seem to be the
perfect solution for that according to
several insiders including Daniel rpk
right now Marvel Studios is discussing
multiple plans for multiple X-Men
projects for New Mutants in the MCU not
just old returning X-Men like Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine Hollyberry storm
Patrick Stewart's Professor Xavier we do
know that those characters are returning
but we are talking about new X-Men in
the MCU so that is super exciting exting
also a little note about this Insider my
time to shine hello states that no young
X-Men are going to return so no James
macavoy Michael fast Bender basically
that X-Men first Class team we shouldn't
expect to really see any of them which
if you think about it it makes sense
because this is a part of Kevin fy's
plan to sort of say goodbye to the
original Fox X-Men characters because he
worked with those people and his very
first project professionally was the
X-Men film in 2000 so it would make
sense that he would bring back those
original characters from that original
trilogy to the MCU since he's the one
who worked with them so don't expect to
see many characters if any of the X-Men
first Class show up in the MCU now
another big team that is coming to the
MCU very soon is the Fantastic 4 now the
film was supposed to begin filming in
January of 2024 so a few days from now
which means we should have had an
official casting announcement within the
next few days however unfortunately
according to Daniel rpk the Fantastic 4
is not going to begin filming until May
of 2024 that means we might not get the
official casting announcement from
Marvel Studios for a pretty long time
now a few months at least but the last
that we've heard Pedro Pascal is
officially our Mr Fantastic and it does
seem like Vanessa Kirby is locked in to
play Sue storm the thing and the Human
Torch reports have all seemed to be kind
of speculative and we don't have
anything solid for them yet so those
character castings are still a mystery
the most sure thing that we have heard
so far though since it's been reported
by many outlets and many insiders is
that Pedro pescal is Mr Fantastic and
another report we've heard is that if
Doom is in the Fantastic 4 movie he is
not going to be a main character or even
kind of a side character but it will be
for a quick Cameo if he shows up at all
now according to The Insider my time to
shine hello and other insiders as well
the villain of the Fantastic 4 movie is
going to be a female heral and galatis
with the speculation being that this
female heral is going to be Juno the
female version of the Silver Surfer and
of course the imminent threat of galatis
coming one rumor about the ending is
that the Fantastic Four will actually
lose and their universe will get
destroyed but right before they get
saved by the TVA then they become a part
of the Multiverse Avengers team and
ultimately after the soft reboot would
end up in the main MCU Universe whatever
that's going to be after Secret Wars now
moving forward with the Avengers films
we have heard from The Insider my time
to shine hello that Tom Holland
Spider-Man is going to be the main focus
of the future Avengers films so that's
Avengers 5 which was previously King
Dynasty and of course Avengers Secret
Wars which could be a two-part movie so
if there are three Avengers films Tom
Holland is supposed to be the star of
all of those and of course if there are
two the same thing according to Insider
Daniel rpk Marvel Studios basically
knows that Spider-Man is one of the most
popular superheroes in the world if not
the most popular superhero so they
really want to focus on him for the next
Avengers films and the the future of the
MCU myad expect to see a lot of
Spider-Man in the future and according
to my time to shine hello Miles Morales
is going to be introduced in the next
few Spider-Man films with Tom Holland so
in Tom Holland Spider-Man 4 five or six
expect to see Miles Morales show up and
Sony also did confirm that they are
working on a Spider-Man Miles Morales
movie it's unclear if they were talking
about the MCU or their own Sony
spiderverse but either way Miles Morales
is coming to the MCU now since Marvel
Studios revealed that secret Wars was
indeed going to be the final movie in
the Multiverse Saga and the fact that we
are in the Multiverse Saga many people
have talked about Robert Downey Jr
returning Scarlett Johansson Chris Evans
and many more and from what we've heard
by many insiders this is true however
they are not going to undo anything that
these characters have done in the past
meaning they are not resurrecting any of
these characters they are simply going
to bring in variants of these characters
played by the same actor so we'll see a
variant of of Iron Man played by Robert
Downey Jr a variant of Black Widow
played by Scarlett Johansson and a
variant of Captain America played by
Chris Evans and I hope we also see Chris
Evans play the Human Torch as well but
we did learn something really
fascinating about Iron Man Black Widow
and Captain America according to my time
to shine Alo they are going to bring
these characters back after the soft
reboot however they will not be played
by Robert Downey Jr Chris Evans and
Scarlett Johansson they are going to
recast the characters and they will
essentially be new characters in this
new universe that is going to be
established after the reboot they are
reportedly doing this so these amazing
characters that we have come to know in
love over the years can now interact
with the X-Men and the Fantastic Four
although they will be different actors
playing the characters now on top of
this we've also gotten many reports
about new characters or new projects
about old characters happening in the
MCU like a World War Hulk project many
insiders including Alex Perez my time to
shine hello can we get some toast Daniel
rpk have all reported about a World War
Hulk project at some point or a solo
Hulk project according to the reports
Marvel Studios does indeed have the
rights back to do a solo Hulk project
and they plan to do that and one thing
they plan to do for a World War Hulk
storyline isn't exactly what they have
done in the comics in fact it's going to
be very different with some insiders
stating that it's a World War hulks
movie so basically what we know is that
Marvel Studios is going to begin
introducing more hulks into the MCU Red
Hulk being one of them She-Hulk
obviously Hulk has his son Scar and
they're going to be more thanks to the
super soldier project that Thunderbolt
Ross has still been trying to make work
so essentially it looks like we're going
to have a battle between good Hulks and
bad hulks in a Solo Hulk project Alex
Perez from the cosmic circus has also
stated that the midnight suns are going
to begin to come to the MCU and Marvel
Studios is developing a project around
them and projects that will continue to
explore this darker corner of the MCU
and introduce members of The Midnight
Sun suns are blade Iron Heart Marvel
Zombies moonight season 2 the
continuation of werewolf by night and
some other unannounced projects as well
now there was talk of a Ghost Rider
special presentation at one point in
time now we know Marvel Studios is kind
of changing the way they do Disney Plus
shows from here on out but hopefully
Marvel studi still has a plan for Ghost
Rider Nova is also apparently still
coming to the MCU according to my time
to shine hello they just simply do not
know when yet and speaking of moonnight
season 2 it has been said that moonnight
season 2 and Miss Marvel season 2 are
being talked about right now at Marvel
Studios this is coming from Daniel rpk
and according to my time to shine hello
a She-Hulk season 2 is also in
discussion right now at Marvel Studios
as well and one of the biggest reports
that we've gotten recently from multiple
insiders is that the beyonder Kang is
going to be the main villain of Avengers
Secret Wars according to multiple
reports it does seem like there is going
to be a Kang variant that is also the
beyonder from what we we know he's going
to come in and essentially defeat the
Council of kings and then from there The
Avengers will try to defeat the king
beyonder variant according to Alex Perez
this will be possible because although
the beyonder king variant will be
stronger than the Council of Kings he
will have a greater weakness to exploit
and we've talked about this a lot but
this is really like Avengers Secret Wars
in the comics where Doom takes the power
of the beyonder and that's sort of how
they defeat him but of course I think
the biggest news that we've heard over
this year is simply the return of many
beloved characters that we've seen
throughout the course of Marvel history
not just the MCU but Marvel overall we
already have hug Jackman returning as
Wolverine that is a crazy big win for
the fandom according to multiple
insiders Toby Maguire Spider-Man is
indeed going to be returning in secret
Wars as well and will fight alongside
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine along with many
other Heroes returning like the original
X-Men and Robert Downey Jr Scarlett
Johansson Chris Evans as their variants
fighting alongside these leg Legacy
Heroes as well I think as Marvel fans
that is just going to be one of the most
amazing things that we could possibly
see ever happen on screen and I can't
wait to see it a lot of these reports
have me super excited for the future of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and I hope
they have you excited as well but let us
know your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well we pick a
winner at the end of each month the
winner picks one item only a few days
left in this month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof